je suis tellement contente d'être ici
avec vous et de partager un sujet qui me
qui m'est très cher donc une pathologie
qui affecte beaucoup de patients en
france mais je vais déjà vous raconter
un petit peu mon histoire donc comme
disait mélissa je suis au top et disent
tu es orthésiste c'est une profession
qui est peu connue encore du grand
public
donc j'ai la chance d'exercer ce métier
qui est passionnant puisque on travaille
avec la tête et on travaille avec les
mains donc c'est absolument génial
donc je fabrique je conçois j'invente je
crée et surtout ged
j'aide les gens dans leur douleur dans
leur manque d'autonomie et aussi dans
leur vie quotidienne
voilà donc tout a commencé il ya
maintenant une bonne dizaine d'années
donc je venais tout juste de débuter
cette profession parce que j'en ai fait
d'autres avant j'ai fait d'autres choses
mais celle ci s'est voilà c'est la bonne
en tout cas donc j'étais chargé donc
auprès du ministère de la santé pour
travailler sur un diplôme d'état écrire
et puis j'ai rencontré un monsieur un
monsieur qui qui est professeurs
universitaires en médecine qui est
anthropologue et puis et puis on papote
évidemment autour d'un d'une table ronde
avec plein de gens et puis il me dit
mais vous faites quoi
alors je dis mais je fais de leur thèse
je crée je fabrique et ben c'est vous
c'est vous dont j'ai besoin
alors je tire à bon ok on va en discuter
dit voilà moi je m'occupe d'une maladie
une maladie qui est pas commune qui est
compliqué et leurs thèses
mais leur thèse c'est le traitement le
traitement au coeur de cette pathologie
donc cette pathologie de l'air dans
l'eau st est ce que ça vous parle de
l'air dans l'eau sans nom ben moi non
plus
parce que ça n'existe pas de l'airbus
par contre le syndrome d'ehlers danlos 1
il existe bien lui c'est une pathologie
du tissu conjonctif alors le tissu
conjonctif c'est quoi c'est un grand mot
qui veut dire plein de choses
le tissu conjonctif et du collagène le
collagène fin c'est une partie de
collège il n'y a pas que du collagène
dans le tissu conjonctif mais le
collagène c'est la colle c'est le tissus
de soutien
donc c'est une pathologie du tissus de
soutien du tissu conjonctif alors
imaginer que notre corps nous êtres
humains en effet de 80% tissu conjonctif
a donc imaginé un petit peu le bordel là
dedans quand même pour le dire 80 %
donc c'est une pathologie qui est multi
systémique et avec une symptomatologie
qui est vaste compliqué à diagnostiquer
justement puisque symptomatologie vaste
sa touche tous les organes donc
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler surtout
de syndrome d'ehlers danlos mais de type
hyper mobile puisque on a plusieurs
types
à ce jour il ya une classification qui
existe les scientifiques les généticiens
les médecins rééducateurs enfin pour les
scientifiques ont une classification
pour le diagnostic
alors il ya le type classique à le type
hyper mobility vasculaire le type six
fosses coolio tic mais celui que je
connais le mieux
c'est le type iii le type hyper mobile
alors le type hyper mobile comme son nom
l'indiqué hyper mobilité hyper
élasticité on peut dire ça aussi des
articulations mais du corps finalement
du corps alors exemple les doigts qui
sont très ip relaxe le pouce très ip
relaxe les genoux les coudes donc
entorse à répétition subluxation
luxation et
pour toute douleur douleur il ya même
des soucis au niveau fonctionnel
situationnelle quand je parle de
situationnelle c'est par exemple se
laver prendre une douche se laver les
cheveux lever les mains pour se frotter
les cheveux tout simplement
et puis la fonction marché monte un
escalier tout ça c'est compliqué et le
pire c'est que c'est une pathologie qui
et invalidante
vous l'avez comprise mais surtout qui et
ça se voit par les gens ils sont ils ont
l'air en super forme tout va bien ils
ont bonne mine
donc en plus on a du mal à les croire
quand même donc
donc voilà pour ceux pour les symptômes
alors évidemment il ya d'autres
symptômes qui vont s'y ajouter il ya
l'asthénie la fatigue les troubles
viscéraux enfin tout ce qui est viscères
coeur poumon enfin tout voilà et puis
pratiquement tous les patients sont des
douloureux mais douloureux chroniques
donc ils vivent dans la douleur
constamment et puis un autre symptôme
qui est pas connue et d'ailleurs en
médecine on en parle on commence à en
parler un petit peu même dans les
universités mais c'est pas c'est pas
encore dans les moeurs
c'est le trouble proprioceptif le
trouble de la proprioception est-ce que
selon vous parle proprioception pas du
tout alors la proprioception pour moi en
tout cas c'est le sixième sens c'est le
schéma corporel
c'est quand on se déplace on sait où est
notre corps on sait que voilà voilà mon
pied il est comme ça bon ben je sais
qu'il est comme ça il ya des gens ils
savent pas alors je vais vous raconter
une petite anecdote
donc j'étais en consultation à l'hôpital
et donc je vois une patiente moyens il
ya un bout de temps il ya bien six ans
maintenant et donc la patiente s'assoit
et je lui demande va écouter maintenant
il va falloir donc ceux des alliés je
vais vous sculpter je vais l'examen
clinique et je lui demande de se lever
bell s'est levé mais elle est tombée
lorsque cette dame avait les jambes
croisées
mais elle avait oublié qu'elle avait les
jambes croisées et elle avait surtout
oublier que sa jambe elle était là et
pas à côté de l'autre voilà l'image que
ça peut vous faire le trouble
proprioceptif est-ce que je feins
j'espère en tout cas que j'ai réussi à
me faire comprendre de ce que c'était
savoir où et sombre à savoir où est sa
jambe
donc ce sont des malades qui ont du mal
à se repérer dans l'espace mais surtout
quand il marche bien il marche mais il
titube
ou alors on peut même les vendre pour
des alcools aux siens parce que dans la
rue ils peuvent vaciller parce que
justement le système proprioceptif le
système postural n'est pas en bonne
forme
tout simplement alors là des petites
images pour vous montrer aussi qu' il ya
des luxations des entorses mais aussi
des ecchymoses mais des ecchymoses
spontané c'est à dire sans traumatisme
voilà parce que ça touche aussi le tissu
cap il ya les capillaires le tissu
conjonctif donc il ya des petits bleus
qui peuvent apparaître sur le corps et
puis on a également donc une peau très
fine ou d'ailleurs on voit bien là sur
la photo le réseau veineux le réseau
veineux superficielle troubles de la
cicatrisation également alors le petit
chat qui fait dodo voilà c'était juste
pour vous montrer qu'il y avait une
grande fatigabilité de ses patients
troubles proprioceptif avec le petit
dessin d'un enfant qui est dyspraxiques
voilà la dce proprioception alors bon
bah tout ça c'est pas cool hein quand
même si même plutôt embêtant alors ben
faut bien quand même les soigner ces
gens là et puis ben figurez vous que ce
fameux médecin a mis en place il ya
quelques années des des traitements mais
des traitements non médicamenteux des
traitements d'orthez des traitements
orthez tic pour remettre les gens droit
traitement atypique un là en
l'occurrence
donc sur l'image vous voyez là un petit
garçon avec des sous vêtements bleus et
le petit l'optima et noir donc ce sont
des vêtements de proprioception ses sous
vêtements
et oui alors le but de ces traitements
c'est devenir comprimer le corps donc si
on comprime le corps on va retirer
resserrer les tissus notre peau ok et
donc on va avoir une meilleure
perception de son corps on va contenir
le corps sans l'immobiliser eh bien
figurez vous que ça marche
c'est dingue mais ça marche donc on
soigne pas tous nos patients j'ai pas
dit qu'on allait 100% de réussite avec
tout ça mais en tout cas on retrouve on
peut redonner de l'autonomie est aussi
un peu d'espoir à nos ânes au malade 1
voilà parce que c'est ça aussi ce dont
ils ont besoin c'est de l' écoute et de
les encourager à aller mieux donc
traitements haart éthiques
voilà c'est mon job moi je suis
orthopédiste et orthésiste donc je fais
une multitude d'orthez et surtout celle
ci voilà et puis on a inventé un gant
alors je pense que il n'ya même pas
besoin d'être en situation de handicap
d'ailleurs parce que quand on a des
difficultés à ouvrir les bocaux les
bouteilles d'eau les canettes de coca
enfin coupé du pinceau tout ce qui est
très fonctionnel à la vie quotidienne
donc on a inventé un gant e jeanne que
je prenne hommes le gant de préhension
donc c'est un gant avec un silicone en
face palmer pour pouvoir aider les gens
à mobilité réduite d'être autonome
voilà ce que c'est rendre les gens
autonomes dans leur vie
alors elle vient d'où cette idée cette
idée géniale de vêtements de compression
c'est un générique de base des vêtements
de compression pour les gens qui ont été
brûlés ok et puis ensuite on s'est dit
mais les gens qui font du sport vous m
vêtements de contention et les gens qui
font de la plongée ils sont habillés en
combi complète on compte envoyer nos
patients un peu un peu comme ça un peu
tordu dit mais si on l'est redresse par
ce genre de combines va peut-être que ça
va marcher
et ben oui ça a marché donc on a fait
une petite étude prospective avait puis
ça a fonctionné alors l'efficacité
efficace pourquoi parce que dans notre
tissu dans votre tissu conjonctif dans
votre peau dans vos temps donc dans vos
muscles dans vos vies sert partout il ya
des capteurs et des récepteurs nouveau
faire quoi ces capteurs et ses
récepteurs et bien ils vont aller
informer le cervelet de la position de
votre corps de ce que vous voyez de ce
que vous mâcher aussi nous comment vous
allez déglutir ça va informer le cerveau
de la position du corps et surtout ça va
aussi inhibés la douleur pourquoi on
appelle ça le gate contrôle 1 je suis
certaine que dans la dans la salle il ya
déjà des gens qui ont utilisé des d
électro stimulation avisé antalgiques
vous avez les petites électrodes qu'on
pose sur un segment pour inhiber la
douleur et bien c'est ça c'est à dire
que en touchant ou en comprimant un
segment où un membre
on va redonner on va donner une autre
information au capteur qui sont des no 6
70 au cervelet donc la douleur elle va
s'estomper
elle revient quand même mais on a un
petit moment de tranquillité
je pense en tout cas c'est je pense que
c'est humain quand on a mal quand on se
brûle qu'est ce qu'on fait on frotte on
se touche
voilà bah si c'était fait là on comprime
pour inhiber la douleur donc au départ
on savait pas ça allait jouer sur la
douleur et finalement avec eux ces
années là qui ont passé finalement ça
joue encore plus sur la douleur que
autre chose donc c'est quand même génial
et puis il ya pas que ça
il n'y a pas que les vêtements de
proprioception ou enfin dit de
compression il ya les orthèses
plantaires donc les semelles dit
orthopédique
alors là ce sont pas des semelles
orthopédiques qui vont remettre droit la
cheville qui vont corriger une statique
mauvaise statique non c'est plus redonné
de la proprioception au pied moi je dis
que le pied c'est la deuxième rétine du
corps mais en même temps c'est un peu
logique quand on marche c'est quand même
le pied qui nous donne l'information
voilà et puis pour traiter donc les
autres types de douleur mais plus
localement on va créer on va fabriquer
toujours sur mesure des autres orthez
des orthèses demain des orthèses de
fonction des orthèses de préhension
l'immobilisation pas trop en tout cas
pour cette pathologie pas trop en règle
générale donc tout ça pour vous dire que
le handicap le handicap qui est que l'on
ne voit pas le handicap invisible
ça existe il ya plein de gens autour de
vous qui ont un handicap invisible la
différence ça tue pas la différence
au contraire la différence ça élève une
personne et quand on peut et est une
personne différente
forcément vous allez également si vous
accomplir dans votre vie de tous les
jours
parce que faire du bien ça fait du bien
alors faut essayer
essayez de devoir le handicap
différemment et de ne pas voir le
handicap de façon négatif mais au
contraire positif on a eu un très bel
exemple pendant les jeux paralympiques
vous avez vu c'était juste fabuleux ce
qui s'est passé donc tout ça pour dire
la différence c'est fabuleux
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]